[Música]
mi nombre es victoria tengo 26 años soy
influye en ser modelo de instagram y
creadora de contenido en las redes
social mi nombre es mariam soy
instagramers o influencer creadora de
redes sociales y tengo 29 años hola soy
guerra y lo son tengo 35 años y soy
modelo profesional masculino y de
pasarela hola soy jessica brum mayor
tengo 19 y soy modelo de pasarela hola
chicos mi nombre es saliste callar tengo
34 años soy modelo internacional hola a
todos soy chantelle tengo 24 años y soy
un influencer badie positiva además de
modelo de curvas pueden ir los modelos
de instagram a la izquierda y los
modelos de pasarela a la derecha
modelo de instagram si estás de acuerdo
ven a centro mi trabajo incluye todo
tipo de cuerpos
razas géneros sexualidades y capacidades
si obviamente el mío es muy inclusivo me
ves ves como me veo a la gente que me
sigue está aquí para ganar confianza
recibo mensajes de mujeres todo el
tiempo me encanta tu aspecto yo también
me veo así siento que cuando crecí
siempre vi modelos que tenían que ser
altos y demás así que me alegro que las
redes sociales te permitan ser como eres
y también ser tú mismo de pequeña nunca
pensé que pudiera ser modelo porque yo
nunca modelo ahora estoy representada
por una agencia trabajo con una marca
mundial nunca pude pensar que eso me
pasaría a mí estoy agradecida
no incluye todos los tipos de cuerpo
porque en general las cosas que llevo no
están hechas para todos los tipos de
cuerpo así que para hacer mi trabajo
tengo que mantener un aspecto
determinado ya saben una forma
determinada para los modelos de pasarela
lo que estos diseñadores crean son
tallas de muestras y tienes que ser
capaz de encajar en las tallas de
muestra por eso supongo que no hay
tantos tipos de cuerpo
pero definitivamente creo que la
industria del modelaje es cada vez más
diversa especialmente hoy en día si me
encantaría decir que la industria del
modelaje incluye a todo el mundo incluye
raza hacia todo el mundo pero es cierto
cuando hablamos de tipo de cuerpo las
personas tienen que tener una
determinada altura y una determinada
forma de cuerpo para poder hacerlo es
como comparar a alguien que juega al
tenis y lo hace por diversión y alguien
que juega profesionalmente y se ha
entrenado durante años para ello como
roger federer no todo el mundo llega a
ser como él y lo mismo ocurre con los
modelos en realidad no elegimos cómo
hemos nacido la altura que tenemos si
nos toca hacer este trabajo las personas
tienen que ser muy delgadas aunque ahora
hay modelos de talla grande pero no en
el medio no hay mercado para la gente
intermedia real y es una pena creo que
eso debería cambiar la mente estuvimos
hablando de ello eres una talla 14 a 16
y yo estoy tamaño de la muestra para
talla grabar el día 14 a 16 es el 1 x es
el estándar para los modelos de kuri y
por ejemplo yo soy de la talla 6 a la 8
y para mí no hay talla de muestra y me
veo obligada a trabajar con las marcas
que son digital es más que de alta
costura y por eso estoy más pegada al
modelaje en instagram porque logro más
que en la pasarela
que cree que es lo más difícil de ser
modelo de pasarela
creo que lo más difícil es que no es
solo un trabajo al que vas sino que es
un estilo de vida que tienes que vivir
cualquiera puedo hacer mi trabajo
no muy bien pasen todos
no creo que sólo puedas ser simplemente
un modelo de pasarela creo que en primer
lugar camarón roussel dio una charla y
habla de que ser modelo es como ganar la
lotería genética hay mucho de suerte
pero también tiene que ver con un estilo
de vida creo que solo las personas que
son muy fuertes de voluntad y
autodeterminación pueden realmente
hacerlo estoy de acuerdo también siento
lo mismo por el instagram el director te
mira te paseas por el programa y listo
para nosotros es diferente tenemos que
construir una comunidad debemos
complacer a cientos de miles de personas
para que nos quieran seguir cada día si
lo piensas reunimos como una pequeña
ciudad como mundos de personas que están
con nosotros ayudándonos y ayudándonos
si nosotros hacemos lo mismo en 2018 por
ejemplo solo en estados unidos serán 257
millones de personas las que tenía un
smartphone y de estas personas el 80%
están en las redes sociales cualquiera
del 80% puede convertirse en un modelo
de instagram y creo que realmente una
porción muy pequeña de personas puede
convertirse
un supermodelo es completamente
diferente porque si quitas el maquillaje
si quitas los filtros si quitas tal vez
la cirugía plástica y todo el retoque
verás lo que es realmente al final no
estoy necesariamente de acuerdo con eso
y puedo decir porque lo que pasa es que
ya no retocamos tanto las fotos porque
hacemos body positivo y deseosos de
mostrar la salud depende de qué pongo ep
si la industria se ha alejado mucho de
lo que solía ser el filtro la crisis y
en todo caso las influencias de hoy en
día estamos tratando de romper eso
estamos tratando de romper los filtros
estamos tratando de romper el escondite
detrás del facebook en photoshop y
cualquier cosa que tengamos
si creo que está empezando a ser más
crudo por eso creo que estamos en
primera línea también estamos publicando
todos nuestros defectos y cada pequeño
rollo y estría y todo y la gente puede
juzgarlo
cómo describirías tu usuario o tu feed
mifid soy más una blogger de estilo de
vida últimamente me concentro mucho en
los deportes y en el entrenamiento y en
cómo estar sano porque estoy muy en
contra de las cirugías plásticas trato
de enfatizar que las personas pueden ser
bellas y saludables trabajando en sí
mismas y comiendo adecuadamente en lugar
de ir al cirujano
me he sometido a una cirugía estética
si
estaba como
bueno me rompí la nariz hace tres años y
no es una historia falsa de hecho mi
nariz sigue estando torcida me la rompí
hace como tres años y tuve que operarme
la y me quite un bulto porque ya lo
estás pagando así que es mejor y seguro
que eso te hizo feliz me hizo muy feliz
sinceramente me sentía insegura con mi
bulldog y recibía muchos comentarios
sabes no necesariamente bueno sobre él
me encantaba pero aún así la gente
estaba como y eso me hizo muy feliz
todavía no arreglaron todo el asunto
pero
por supuesto existe un aumento de pecho
de acuerdo si es sólo una mejora era
algo que me iba a ser más feliz así que
lo hice por confiando bien por ti sí
gracias eso sí siento que los asiáticos
no estamos dotados y estamos dotados con
nuestra genética los asiáticos no
envejecen pero cuando se trata de
nuestro cuerpo tenemos que conseguir
financiación o trabajar mucho en él
cuando era pequeña tenía una nariz muy
pequeña y graciosa y me decía ah dios
mío no me gusta mi nariz tenía una forma
rara y cuando crecí siendo modelo los
fotógrafos decían dios mío nos encanta
tu nariz yo decía que yo
y realmente me enseñó a aceptarla y
ahora la amo estoy muy contenta nunca
pensé en operarme la nariz ni nada
parecido pero me enseñó a quererme tal
como soy entonces bueno yo he tenido una
experiencia similar soy medio japonés
así que no fui bendecida con curvas y
eso no me gustaba cuando me veían
pensaba que no lucía atractiva porque no
tengo senos tampoco trasero pero tan
pronto llegue al mundo del modelaje fue
como hoy es algo bueno es bueno ser más
plana estoy orgullosa de eso creo que
para mí siendo todo inclusivo es un poco
realmente no puedo decir que no haga
nada porque eso supone que apoyo todos
los tipos de cuerpo como sea que vengas
como sea que quieras venir es como te
acepto pero creo que donde estoy ahora
mismo 100% natural creo que es donde me
gustaría quedarme solo por mi mensaje a
todos los que me están viendo ahora
mismo tal vez en un par de años después
de un par de niños
de nuevo o algo así así que no voy a
decir nunca y no estoy de acuerdo pero
para dónde estoy en mi espacio ahora
mismo definitivamente admiro la
verdadera belleza admiro a la gente como
viene viene natural y creo que en todo
caso te hace más único que es lo más
difícil de su trabajo
es estar al día es salir siempre con
nuevas ideas nuevas fotos nuevos
conjuntos asegurarse de que la foto
siempre sea perfecta cuando la publiques
creo que retocar mi cuerpo con photoshop
está bien
a mi gente
bueno en mi caso cuando pienso en el
photoshop que puede ser diferente al de
ustedes muchas de las fotos en las que
aparezco puede que tenga acné ese día y
muchas veces lo eliminan con ese
programa ni de tener la piel clara y
para mí eso está bien porque son cosas
si el desaparecen sin embargo para el
cuerpo no estoy de acuerdo no lo
comparto tengo que admitir que alguna
vez se ha retocado mis fotos con
photoshop pero es solo para mejorar la
foto y hacerla aparecer de una manera
determinada pero sigo siendo quien soy
no es que me vea diferente creo que
mientras no veas a la gente en persona y
te digan
creo que está bien como has dicho cuando
sales en las revistas he visto mis fotos
en icon y los museos están listos no es
slim y si sabes que es o bien de la
rumba eso que los clientes quieren ver y
estoy perfectamente de acuerdo con eso
no me parece bien
[Risas]
tengo una curiosidad antes de empezar
nunca les han retocado las fotos nunca
nadie ha retocado sus fotos de ninguna
mano la pregunta es si nos parece bien
esa es una pregunta de un gerente
firmado porque niños dijo que ella no
está diciendo que nunca retoque mis
fotos sí pero eso no hace que esté bien
digamos que tampoco me gusta demasiado
el maquillaje sabes a qué me refiero
pero creo que cuando se trata de retocar
no tengo el control de la imagen yo hago
el trabajo en luego ellos tienen el
control de esa imagen si me tocará a mí
me gustaría ser lo más natural posible
porque soy un ser humano y por eso tengo
defectos y estoy agradecido por mi
aspecto pero no soy perfecto me gustaría
representar me a mí mismo me gustaría
ser quien soy y luego miró esos filtros
y la gente parece extraterrestre ni
siquiera parece medios ese filtro es
loco qué es eso pero rechazaría es un
trabajo si supieras que te van a hacer
una edición con fotos si me van a ser
una edición con photoshop entonces no
voy a hacer el trabajo
entonces también podrían conseguir
cualquier cosa sabes lo que hice y le ha
parecido bien retocar su cuerpo a través
de photoshop y me parece bien y mientras
mi foto se vea bien y no aparezca un
reloj de arena me parece muy bien pero
como se decide si te parece bien
entonces te parece bien que hagan lo que
quieran yo tengo mi propio fotógrafo y
maquillador y mi fotógrafo edita mis
fotos así que siempre podemos colaborar
en la remodelación y otras cosas así que
no es como una revista
qué es lo mejor del trabajo lo mejor son
los seguidores las chicas que me mandan
mensajes y me dicen me das mucha
confianza y me encanta tu aspecto y
ahora puedo salir y lucir así también
así que eso es definitivamente lo que me
da un impulso son las chicas en las que
influyó me preocupa la influencia que
tengo a la imagen corporal de las chicas
y los chicos
jóvenes
así que creo que en cualquiera que
trabaje con la imagen y que tenga a su
imagen ahí fuera tiene la
responsabilidad de enviar realmente un
mensaje positivo y saludable
por ejemplo recuerdo que cuando empecé a
trabajar como modelo siempre me decían
oh tienes que perder peso tienes que
perder peso y yo podría haber seguido
ese camino pero decidí perder un poco
para ajustarme al tamaño de la muestra
pero no quise seguir ese camino porque
no es saludable y entonces estoy dando
un ejemplo para las mujeres más jóvenes
van a pensar que esa es la imagen de la
belleza van a pensar que está bien hacer
eso me preocupa mucho los implantes de
trasero porque la gente casi le muere
por ello y literalmente empiezo a hacer
ejercicio cinco veces a la semana vaya
de verdad y solo para mostrarles que se
puede construir el trasero lo tienes de
forma natural y smartphone
y me gustaría tenerlo y trato de hacerlo
crecer pero ya sabes
y también creo que los modelos de curvas
nos ocupamos el otro extremo de es
demasiado es demasiado grande sabes está
la obesidad está diciendo que está bien
ser poco saludable y creo que como
modelo con curvas es nuestra
responsabilidad decir oye si tenemos
curvas pero seguimos promoviendo estilos
de vida saludables le digo a las chicas
que me siguen si puede que tenga algo de
espalda aquí pero sigo comiendo mi
brócoli en donde esté
bueno en mi caso nunca pensé que tuviese
ninguna influencia
cada vez que hace una sesión de
fotografías o algo así nunca pensé que
otras personas lo verían pero cuanto más
pienso en ello supongo que si tengo
algún tipo de influencia no tanto como
las modelos de instagram porque toda su
vida está expuesta las personas ven mis
imágenes y son solo eso mis imágenes y
me gusta pensar que influyó en la gente
de forma positiva porque no soy la
modelo más delgada de mi agencia nunca
he tenido ningún trastorno alimenticio
así que me gusta pensar que aunque no
haya pensado demasiado en ello estoy
influyendo positivamente en las personas
que me miran si creen como influencia es
nuestra responsabilidad es probablemente
solo las cosas que publicamos y el grado
de publicar píldoras de dieta y cosas de
ese tipo como batidos y ustedes y
cualquier cosa que te haga ensuciar lo
espanto
la responsabilidad es solo a filtrar lo
que estamos publicando cuando se trata
de patrocinios y estoy de acuerdo con
algo primero tengo que probar el
producto sí así que después de probarlo
si no funciona les diré que no funciona
y que no quiero ir adelante así que
depende puedes enumerar los que crees
que son tus mayores logros como modelo
de pasarela he trabajado para
diseñadores como alexander mcqueen he
desfilado pool costello grandes
diseñadores puedo permitirme la ropa que
modelo y promoción
a veces bueno
a veces a veces es muy cierto para mí
bueno
todos sabemos que la mayoría de las
influencias trabajan como emergente por
lo que obtenemos la ropa cuanto antes
puedes conseguir un millón de esos
mismos y vendidos y todos los tenemos
puestos así que acaso soy una estudiante
arreglada porque mis hijos son muy bajos
y solo consigo dinero de un par de
actuaciones como modelo la mayoría de
las veces goodwill es mi recurso en
primer lugar no puedo permitirme todo lo
que me pongo porque no me compraría un
traje de cinco o diez mil dólares y
simplemente no tiene sentido para mí
también hay una cosa que es recibir
cosas gratis y además no cobrar así que
hay niveles para ello diría yo así que
si hago cosas por la ropa gratis y no me
pagan entonces no voy a ser capaz de
pagar nada porque no estoy recibiendo el
pago
y me parece que muchas veces un buen
porcentaje de influencers o modelos de
instagram son simplemente como voy a
hacerlo por la ropa no puedo pagar mis
facturas con ropa no puedo pagar nada
con ropa muchos modelos de instagram
solo buscan conseguir ropa gratis así
que de repente las marcas simplemente no
pagan en los modelos y toman modelos de
instagram y así completamente la tarde
unidades así que es un problema en
nuestra industria me he dado cuenta de
que en los últimos años las tarifas son
increíblemente bajas sí para usos que
son increíblemente altos y quizás
alguien va a decir que sí solo porque
quiere ser visto exacto tenemos que
saber nuestro valor para nosotros
funciona así se empieza con ropa gratis
y ustedes me corrigen para ustedes fue
diferente comienza con ropa gratis dices
que está bien para construir la relación
con la marca luego tienes ropa y te
pagan por ejemplo yo vivo plenamente de
mi instagram me mantengo puedo pagar mis
facturas mi auto mi alquiler estoy muy
orgullosa ahora ellos también van a
malvender t así que si vas a dejar de
ganar dinero pero todos van a empezar a
hacerlo por menos y menos y menos el
final del día vamos a es cierto porque
nos quieren por nuestros seguidores nos
quieren por nuestro aspecto eso es
cierto pero y la creación de alimentos
buscan influencias que vendan las
imágenes tienen calidad están publicando
constantemente por supuesto hay gente y
que dice si voy a publicar en mi patio
con mi iphone y simplemente no funciona
en los estos influencers definitivamente
se desvanecen que es lo más difícil de
ser un modelo de pasarela no estar
seguro de cuándo vas a trabajar después
y llenar tu tiempo siendo un ser humano
pero sin saber sin tener el control de
tu día supongo eso sería todo para mí
mi trabajo ha afectado a mi salud mental
trabajando en este medio durante 15 años
ha habido olas que yo era como vaya
realmente pongo mi valor en lo que
piensan los demás si consigo un empleo
se basa en lo que alguien diga o me
gusta tu aspecto que es algo muy mínimo
para poder juzgar a una persona bueno
tienes muchas cosas dentro de ti empecé
a modelar en nueva york donde incluso
cuando empecé no había muchos de los
otros hombres de raza negra y tener que
ser el único romper la barrera o ir al
casting y bueno él es demasiado oscuro
no puedo hacer nada por ser oscuro o no
pero me rompió un poco y tendría que
dejar la ciudad tenía que ir a nueva
york a trabajar porque no podía hacerlo
en el lugar donde quería vivir
definitivamente
afectó a mi salud mental durante un
tiempo si buscaran este este cierto
aspecto les encanta usar esta palabra
racialmente ambiguo cosas así y es como
quieres un modelo negro qué demonios
porque estás contando a otra persona que
está tratando de imitar a un modelo
negro subiendo y aquí
se convirtió en un juego de números el
compromiso los comentarios los likes así
que seguro tuvo un efecto en mí así que
si una foto no está funcionando bien
empiezo a pensar y sobre pensaría decir
me vaya que hice mal o debería borrar
esta publicación así que es como
eso y no tengo tantos seguidores
empecé a ser modelo a los 20 años en lo
que se considera tarde para el negocio y
creo que estoy muy agradecida de haber
empezado tarde en el negocio porque si
hubiera empezado los 14 años como muchas
chicas lo que te dice tu agente lo que
te dice el cliente te afecta mucho te
tomas todo lo que te dicen como si fuera
la verdad que bien necesitas perder peso
bien voy a hacerlo necesitas lucir así
bien voy a hacerlo empezar siendo mayor
me dio la oportunidad de tener esa
madurez pero no significa que no me
afectará por supuesto quieres que te
contraten quieres gustar el cliente así
que intentas agradar a todo el mundo
pero nunca puedes agradar a todo el
mundo siempre hay un cliente al que no
le va a gustar tu aspecto o no le va a
gustar tu forma de caminar o tu persona
a donde un velo sea lo que sea le
destroza básicamente así que fue muy
duro porque puedes empezar este trabajo
con mucha confianza pero la industria te
va a deslizar y entonces se trata de
aceptarme a mí mismo y ser como sabes
que no necesito tu validación no
necesito eso y cuando llegas debes
construir te de nuevo y ahora voy a los
trabajos y digo te gustó genial si no te
gusta el siguiente está ahí no pasa nada
y solo tienes que dejarlo pasar no pasan
hacia el siguiente está bien y si no es
así
[Risas]